the more law enforcement officers that
are willing to acknowledge prohibition
is wrong the better off society is going
to be after Washington state voters
legalized recreational marijuana a brand
new million dollar industry opened up
and while there are a lot of changes
that are still being worked out in the
state one of the biggest may be Drug
Enforcement agents going to work in the
private sector we sat down with Patrick
mone a former special agent for the DEA
he's been in law enforcement for over 15
years but left to work for a company
called privateer holdings a private
equity firm that invests in cannabis why
did you approach privateer holdings in
the first place what were you looking to
do here why does big move well I was
considering a number of job
opportunities I had pre fulfilling
career at the EA but I was ready for
some new challenges and I wasn't looking
in this industry in particular but it
was one particular industry that that in
that interested me what do you see the
future for privateer holdings what are
you going to invest in we're focused on
branding and creating mainstream brands
when it comes down to it it's a
mainstream product that's been
marginalized our goal ultimately is to
provide them with safe clean access to a
tested safe product in so doing will
remove the black market and bring the
entire industry into the light did any
of your co-workers that you worked with
at the DDA what did they have to say
when you you know packed up your your
desk with all of your stuff in a brown
box and we're walking out the door and
you said goodbye what did they say I got
a lot of congratulations I had a lot of
guys express the belief that I was a
trendsetter or a pioneer which is a
little surprising in time I got a lot of
support I got a few guys asking me for
jobs yeah it was it was pretty positive
since joining privateer holdings your
presence is sort of sparked with maybe
called a media frenzy more journalists
are fascinated with this with this move
of yours that you've made why do you
think that people are so interested I
think that I mean we've all heard the
term
the blue line or the blue wall right
that a lot of law enforcement are either
reluctant or prohibited to speak to the
press and so it's a lot of the
fascination I think stems from the
ability to maybe get a bit of an inside
look some of these organizations that
previously were pretty unknown to most
of the public we all know that the end
of prohibition is coming and I think
everyone recognizes that and taking that
first step is often the most difficult
one it just so happened I was the one to
take it have you consumed marihuana
yourself I have but it's been 20 years
in that 20 years did you have
experiences with people you've met or
maybe family members that began to
change your mind maybe that maybe when
you were a young person I don't think it
was experiences with family or friends
really so much as my experiences on the
job and as my as things evolved as my
viewpoint evolved as I spent more time
on the job I began to realize that
enforcing the marijuana statutes as
they're written was was just an
ineffective use of our resources and
that you can say headache that's fine
yeah it wasn't someone it wasn't a
headache because it wasn't you know it's
it's no more work than any other case
that we do right it's just a matter of
did we focus on this issue or do we
focus on another issue and my personal
belief and I think is a belief that was
shared by many of my colleagues was that
we should focus on other issues mostly
the so-called hard drugs the ones that
we feel have an actual law that I feel
have an actual detrimental effect on
society the US has been fighting the
drug war for over 40 years now do you
think the war on drugs will come to an
end at some point I don't know that's
that's a really complex question
obviously I think that the war on
marijuana will come to an end
fairly soon
I think the inevitability has you know
has reached everyone at this point why
not harder drugs then well I mean my own
personal point of view is that drugs
like methamphetamine and heroin have
legitimate observable harmful effects to
the user and people around the user and
you definitely cannot say the same about
cannabis I mean they're they're not in
the same category you can't even talk
about them in the same context so I
think they're totally separate
discussions you know the US Justice
Department's 2013 national drug threat
assessment said that the availability
was increasing for heroin it was also
increasing for methamphetamine I mean
and I know these numbers fluctuates from
year to year to year but what we really
be able to live in a world where we can
stop people from doing this drug no
never I mean our mission the mission at
DEA was really to keep it under control
right I don't think anyone was under the
illusion that we were going to stop it
that we're going to win the war on drugs
or they were trying to minimize the
Associated harms and when it comes down
to it we're sticking our thumbs in the
dike and there's only so much we can do
you know we tried to attack choke points
try to limit supply there's little we
can do about the man as long as the
demand continues to exist there will
always be supply but there will also be
DEA agents like your former self banging
their head against the wall that's true
I'm you know it's a I guess it comes
down to a cost-benefit analysis right or
is the job at the DEA doing producing a
measurable benefit there are some cases
of mine in particular that I'm very
proud of that I can look back at and say
I had a measurable effect on this
community for some period of time before
it bounced back so you know part of DA's
role I think is to try and keep things
under control to a degree
long-term are we gonna succeed who knows
do you ever think you will go back and
work at the DEA no really why not
now that ship has sailed I think I had a
really fulfilling career there I just
felt like it was time for new
opportunities there's really nothing
there for me anymore
I don't regret having work there do you
think that people like you that go and
work in the private sector from coming
from government coming from the DEA do
you fear that it could create a world
where there might be a revolving door
where the regulator's go and work for
the regulated well I mean that's a
pretty common occurrence already right
in government yeah but not necessarily a
great thing right there's some debate
over whether it's a benefit or not I
mean I think everyone agrees in this
particular instance it is a benefit you
know what the future holds I don't know
but I think that the important fact is
going to be you're the important
consideration will be what are the
attitudes and beliefs of these people
the more law enforcement officers that
are willing to acknowledge that
prohibition is wrong the better off
society is going to be what do you say
to the people that say it's not the DEA
agents themselves it's the system it's
the over forty years of the war on drugs
the the mentality that we're going to
crack down on something that we can't
stop ever I say they're not wrong you
know we've we've perpetuated an idea
that that certain behavior is wrong and
I'm concerned that maybe we're not
looking at things objectively anymore
that we need to really stop and look at
are we doing these things for the right
reason and when it comes to marijuana
the policies that are in place right now
official policies I mean guidance to
Washington State excluded are wrong
they're misguided and
hopefully that's going to change soon is
there anything people would be surprised
about working as a special agent for the
DEA hmm okay and I like the vending
machines suck or something I mean you
know I think that there are there's a
certain subset of the population that
views DEA agents as jackbooted thugs
that have an agenda to oppress them or
to who knows right but it's just another
job and there are guys there that are
very competent there are guys there that
are less so but they're all trying to do
the job the best that they can
when it comes to marijuana I think that
they would be might be surprised to know
that the overwhelming majority of the
agents at least that I ever interacted
with don't feel that marijuana is a
priority and you guys discussed this
smoking a bowl after after a long day
right we discussed it I think that's
where the analogy is with that yeah